and the Oscar goes to
James Ivory call me by your name
my rule number one for a screenwriter
who adapts a novel has first thanked the
author Andreas
who wrote the story about first love and
who's here tonight I want to thank our
sensitive and sensible director with the
guadalino as well as my neighbors in
Upstate New York Peter steers and Brian
swartzstrom who offered me this job
and of course I want to thank the film's
wonderful emotion-filled actress and I
wouldn't be standing up here without the
inspired help I received from my life's
Partners who are gone
our writer Ruth javala who received this
award twice and our fearless producer
Ismail Merchant working with them for
close to 50 years of merchant Ivy led me
to this award and my profound thanks to
the members of the academy in voting for
me you are remembering them
thank you very much everyone
[Applause]